remember that meeting in Trump Tower
with the Russian lawyer Natalia vessel
Mnet's kaya the premise of the meeting
was she was coming to the Trump campaign
with dirt on Hillary and we've learned
about this implicit quid pro quo in
exchange for the reduction of Russian
sanctions if Donald Trump were to win at
least partially based on that dirt on
Hillary that Natalya vessel that's kaya
was proposing she had and at the meeting
we learned that Donald Trump jr.
attended we learned that Paul Manafort
was there we learned that Jared Kushner
and others were there and we were told
by them this was no big deal there was
nothing to see there nothing came of the
meeting there was no follow-up we barely
even remember that the meeting took
place the questions that came from it
were welded Donald Trump senior know
about it last week in congressional
testimony behind closed doors Donald
Trump jr. refused to disclose the
conversations that he had with his
father about its citing attorney-client
privilege despite the fact that neither
Donald Trump jr. nor Donald Trump senior
are attorneys which was weird but the
story continued the story continued as
nothing else happened there was no
follow-up and it led to nothing until
now we knew that the meeting in Trump
Tower had been arranged by a British
publicist named Rob Goldstone and we
have now learned another one of these
lies falling apart that after the Trump
Tower Russia meeting there were
follow-up emails to Russian participants
in the meeting and to inner circle
members of the Donald Trump campaign in
other words we were told there was no
follow-up we went to the meeting we were
there 20 minutes it was clear that there
was nothing to it and that was it we
learned that that was allow Ally there
was actually follow-up we were told that
there wasn't and there was now did we
find out about the follow-up because
everybody involved decided hey you know
what we haven't been honest about this
let's be super upfront all of a sudden
no we found out about it because
congressional investigators discovered
that these emails existed
when they were preparing for Donald
Trump juniors hearing last week which
included the email follow-up now the the
additional thing that we learned from
those emails is that there were also
other relevant topics discussed in that
infamous Trump Tower meeting we were
told that the topic of the meeting was
just Russian adoption and nothing else
well we later learned that Russian
adoption is code for Russian sanctions
which was part of that proposed quid pro
quo but we also learned that the real
reason for the meeting was dirt on
Hillary from the Russian lawyer but now
we've also learned that the meeting and
the email follow-up wanted Donald Trump
to create a page on a Russian social
networking website called VK and in fact
we now have an email that was written to
dance Covino dance Covino was a senior
aide to the Trump campaign telling him
dawn and Paul are on board with the idea
of making a Donald Trump page on VK Don
and appall referencing Donald Trump jr.
and Paul Manafort one of whom has
already been indicted by the way the
Trump campaign expectedly
obviously downplaying this they say well
nothing came of the follow-up but that's
moving the goal posts the first post was
there was no Russian meeting then there
was a Russian meeting but it was only
about adoption then okay there was a
Russian meeting but it was about
adoption and about getting dirt on
Hillary but we never got the dirt and
there was no follow-up and now we've
learned there was follow-up but there
was no action taken in the course of the
follow-up its lies on top of lies and of
course Donald Trump jr. just can't
recall how these exchanges went he will
hopefully go completely off kilter on
Twitter soon and speaking of which
Democratic congressman Joaquin Castro is
on the Intelligence Committee he
appeared on CNN after this hearing with
Donald Trump jr. and he said in
absolutely no uncertain terms this is
huge and this is growing and big things
are coming soon here's what the
congressman had to say
congressman you just said we're going to
be seeing things equally disturbing in
the coming days what are you suggesting
well as you know I can't discuss most of
that stuff now but you know I told you
months ago and when I said it back then
I think it was considered a little bit
brash but I said I think in April that I
thought that there would be people who
would end up in jail and and as I stand
here now I think that there gonna be
some things that come out that will be
very surprising and disturbing to the
American people can you give us just a
hint when you think this will happen
will it be days from now weeks months
well we're on an accelerated schedule
now at least in the house investigation
and Robert Moeller I think is moving
even faster than the house in the Senate
so I would expect that it's safe to say
in the next few months more arrests
quite possibly yes that's what you're
that what you anticipate it wouldn't
surprise me
wow he's talking about months which gets
me back to what I've been saying since
last week given what we're learning
every day
imagine what we will know in three
months because every day it goes deeper
join us on our david pakman show
subreddit discuss these and any other
stories of interest to you with other
David Pakman show viewers and listeners
at david pakman.com slash our IDI di t
we'll take a quick break and be back
after this with so much more support for
today's episode of the david pakman show
comes from health IQ health IQ believes
that the best way to improve the health
of the world is to celebrate the health
conscious through social and financial
rewards so what they do is use science
and data to secure lower rates on life
insurance for health-conscious people
this includes runners cyclists strength
trainers people who eat healthy and much
more 56% of health IQ customers save
between four and thirty three percent on
their life insurance and these are
exclusive savings to health IQ it's sort
of like saving money on your car
insurance because you're a good driver
health IQ allows you to get lower rates
on life insurance or living a
health-conscious
lifestyle and it makes sense we know
that physically active people have a 34%
lower risk of all-cause mortality
health-conscious people physically
active people have a 56% lower risk of
heart disease compared to people who
remain inactive so then the data are
very clear
why can't you save some money as a
result to see if you qualify you can get
your free quote today at health iq.com
slash Pakman or mention the promo code
Pakman that's PA que ma n when you talk
to a health IQ agent that is health IQ
comm / Pakman to get your free quote